it's that driving force of of public
service III know that there are many
many professions and avocations that
people can have many of them are very
noble and very worthy for myself
personally I'm I'm driven by this whole
issue of public service and being able
to do things that will ultimately help
people in my specific arena that happens
to be health but there are many public
servants who help people in many other
ways mine happens to be in health and
the idea that I can marshal my energies
and whatever talent or intellect that I
have to drive myself towards being a
public servant and making a contribution
that will be lasting in the arena of
public health is really the the fuel for
my engine it just keeps me going
I enjoy very much communication I think
that scientists need to communicate the
field of science needs to communicate
with the general public because the
ultimate goal of science is to do good
to gain knowledge to understand and
discover things that are ultimately for
the good of mankind one of the things
that we don't necessarily do very well
all the time is communicating in
language that people can understand the
importance of science and scientific
advances and what they might mean to
people so although that isn't a
scientific talent or something that has
to do with your scientific capability I
find that that I enjoy that it's it's
relatively easy for me and and I know
that when you do communicate the
importance of science the people that
would energize them to support science
even more than we support it because
science is one of the most important
things that we can support in our
society
you know there really isn't there are a
number of people in in different arenas
that I see and I say wow that that
person is really somebody very special
when you think in terms of public
service I heard so much about what
Mother Teresa had done in her life and I
was fortunate enough to get a chance to
meet her and talk to her a lot about
what motivates her and what drives her
and that to me is is a person that
really is an extraordinary role model so
I would say that that is one person
among many relatively unsung people who
who I think really a different have done
and are doing a terrific job